m c'est la grosse ouais c'est la grosse
vache pourquoi t'es grosse ouais
pourquoi c'est parce qu'elle bouge trop
que c'est devenu une grosse boulette
[Musique]
pour l'écriture du film j'ai eu
l'immense chance d'intégrer un groupe de
parole qui s'appelle obèses anonymes ou
plusieurs personnes en situation
d'obésité se retrouvent pourra parler en
fait de leur quotidien et leurs
souffrances
je n'aurais pas imaginé que ces
personnes faisait face à autant de de
discrimination de remarques de
méchanceté de moqueries de violence
gratuite qu'elle soit psychologique ou
physique en allant jusqu'à de la
violence gynécologique en passant par un
petit copain honteux par une maman qui
achetaient des crèmes contre la
cellulite aaa sa petite fille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup de gens pensent que les
personnes sont obèses uniquement parce
qu'elles sont feignants tout parce
qu'elles ne font pas de sport ou
qu'elles ont une alimentation très
mauvaise mais le problème est encore une
fois c'est de ne pas prendre en compte
l'intégralité des multiples facteurs
dire seulement à quelqu'un de faire du
sport ça ne traite absolument pas
l'aspect psychologique qui peut y avoir
derrière les traumas ou pourquoi la
personne en est arrivé là
une phrase extrêmement importante du
film qui m'a été re dit plusieurs fois
par les personnes que j'ai pu avoir la
chance de t2 d'interroger sais je mange
mes émotions
elle est plus grosse que moi alors c'est
qu'une enfant
[Musique]
dans ce genre de moments je me nourris
pas jeu - je me dis motion guérison
gouffre et les abeilles pour lui au glee
ne les remarquent les injonctions à la
minceur se révèle être être extrêmement
traumatisantes pour beaucoup de
personnes qui au final au lieu de penser
que ça va les aider ou les faire changer
très souvent ça a tendance à aller les
faire sombrer encore plus ça peut aussi
créer ce qu'on appelle l'effet yoyo
c'est à dire que la personne va se
motiver puis va perdre un peu de poids
[ __ ] qu'on va en reprendre énormément
ce qui va évidemment comment dire
démotivés la personne sap eu à faire
entrer en dépression il faut vraiment
comprendre que toutes ses injonctions
cette façon de faire ces moqueries sont
des choses qui peuvent détruire des
personnes et les marques et sur toute
une vie il est vraiment important que
l'on puisse évoluer sur sur ce sujet
remettre en question des préjugés que
l'on peut avoir est évidemment parfois
ce qui nous semble bon pour nous n'est
pas forcément pour les autres